- Welcome back to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
As always, I'm just honored to be able
to host these conversations.
As you'll notice in these
recent conversations,
we're bringing in some
different types of topics,
wanna kind of keep things
fresh and relevant,
but also just get at the heart
of really some important issues.
So today we're jumping in
and talking about Black bodies
and race in art and society,
and I have two wonderful guests
who I think you all are really
gonna enjoy hearing from.
They already had some
good chemistry together,
off camera, offline.
So I'm actually really curious
to see where this
conversation is gonna go today
with this important topic.
But by way of introduction,
gonna go ahead first and
introduce Daniel Swann.
Daniel is an assistant professor
of sociology at Goucher College.
He completed his doctorate in sociology
at the University of
Maryland and then, or also,
before that earned his
undergrad degree at Rutgers.
He's taught a whole host of
courses, including courses on
comparative social media, Generation Z,
race and ethnic relations,
social movements,
wealth, power, and prestige,
and also data analytics.
So a wide range of topics.
He also has academic interest
in race, atheism and religion,
and political sociology
and social psychology.
He's the author of some books,
has also contributed
to some book chapters.
One book I wanted to highlight
is his qualitative study of
Black atheists, "Don't Tell
Me You're One of Those"
that was published in 2020.
In addition to the work
that he's been doing,
he also taught at University Park Maryland
before joining where he is now.
So, Danny, just wanted
to welcome you again
to the Addy Hour podcast.
- Awesome. It's great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
- And yeah.
- Of course.
- Chemistry, you know, just makes me think
that things are gonna
gonna go really well, so.
- Yes, (chuckling) I
anticipate that as well.
My second guest I would like
to introduce is Imo Imeh,
who is a visual artist and a
scholar of African diaspora art
whose work considers historical
and philosophical issues
around the black body
and cultural identity.
His work has been exhibited
in numerous venues
across the Northeast and the US.
His work is also represented
in the Petrucci Foundation
Collection of African-American Art,
also in the museum collection
of the University of
Massachusetts Amherst.
His work's been featured on PBS News Hour,
New England Public Media,
and other places as well.
And this year in 2023,
he has actually partnered
with the Medical Journal
of Biological Psychiatry
to have his work appear on
the cover of six issues.
And that's something that I've been able
to be involved in, as well.
So grateful for the work
he's doing on many fronts.
Imo, as someone who actually graduated
from Columbia University in 2022.
Oh my goodness, that'd be nice.
2002. (chuckling)
And then earned his PhD in
history of African-American art
at Yale, where we actually
overlapped as a grad student.
So Imo, thanks so much for being here
on the Addy Hour Podcast.
- Thank you so much.
Wonderful to be with you, Nii,
and wonderful to be with you, Daniel.
- Excellent. I'm not trying
to make you too young.
That was just a slip of the
song at that point. (chuckling)
I don't know if that's good or bad,
but I'm just gonna leave that one there.
- Hey.
I teach a writing for
art and the artist course
at Westfield State University,
and I start off the course by
showing my students a paper
that was heavily destroyed
by one of my professors
when I was in college.
And I put it up and it said
2001, and you heard the gasps.
- Oh no. (chuckling)
- 2001? Now stop it.
Yes. I am that old. Yes.
- Yeah, yeah.
We got that gray going.
Danny, somehow you're keeping,
you're avoiding that so far.
So I'm impressed.
- Yeah, I graduated undergrad in '08
so I got a few years.
- [Nii] All right. You got some time.
- I'm hoping I follow my older
brother's aging patterns,
so yeah, he looks 35 still.
- Oh my goodness. Well,
if you learn some secrets,
pass them along.
So just to jump in, as my listeners know,
I often just like to do a check-in.
I appreciate you all kind of sharing
some of those stories already,
but just to see how you all
are doing at this point in 2023
with everything that
you're doing on campus,
everything we're navigating
as a society. So Danny,
if we can actually start
with you, that'd be great.
- Yeah, I'm doing really well.
Professionally, I have a few
things that I'm working on
and hope to finish up a couple of them
during my sabbatical in 2024.
So I'm really looking forward to that.
I've got something coming
out on political rhetoric.
I've got something coming out on race
and interpersonal interactions and maybe
a group processes thing coming out too.
I'm really excited about that.
I've got some student
collaboration going on as well.
Also putting together my
tenure portfolio here.
So it's quite the hectic time.
But yeah, I'm looking forward to getting
all those projects off the desk
during the sabbatical and out.
So everything there is
good. My family is great.
Like, you know, soccer's
a big part of my life
'cause of my son.
He's awesome. Shout out to
Friends United, by the way.
And yeah. So everything
there is just really good,
just chugging along,
trying to like I said,
get this work out.
- Yeah. Yeah.
That's great to hear.
Definitely appreciate you
sharing that and not surprising,
you've got your hands in so many things
with so many projects going on,
just from what I know of you,
so that's encouraging to hear.
- Yep. Yep. Hard for me to say no.
Thanks for asking though.
- Of course. Imo what about you?
- Yeah, we're plagued by the same demons
in terms of an inability to say no.
I thought I had shaved down
what I was gonna be doing
for, you know, about a year ago.
I canceled a bunch of things.
People were very upset,
and I am still overwhelmed.
There's so much going on right now.
I'm already planning out into 2024,
so this is gonna be interesting. I just,
on the heels of the opening of the first
major comprehensive solo
exhibition of my studio projects,
"Benediction" and "in his name,"
that exhibition is titled
"The Hope of Radiance"
at the August Wilson African
American Cultural Center
in Pittsburgh. It's just...
It is a stellar exhibition.
The installation is exquisite.
It's way beyond what I expected it to be.
And so that's very exciting.
I just curated a group show that is up
at Westfield State University titled
"Something Extraordinary: A Visual Review
of 'Story' as Timeless."
So they're eight African diaspora artists
that I've brought together
to have a conversation
about story with their artwork.
And it's a very expressive,
amazing exhibition.
The artist's are all very
excited to be a part of it.
And I'm currently putting
together a group show
that will involve myself,
and I think it's six other people now,
but it's called "The Miracle Machine."
It's gonna be in the fall.
And we don't know what it is we're doing.
There's a musician, there's
three, four artists.
Someone said the title
should be, you know,
"Four artists, a musician
and a poet walk into a Gap."
And we don't know what we're gonna create.
And so UMass Amherst is very excited.
It's gonna be like an
incubator think tank space
that will grow over the
course of the fall semester.
So anxiety, because I don't know exactly
what will come of it, but
that's where we are right now.
So, other things, but I'll stop there.
- Yeah, well, I appreciate you
sharing that honestly, as well.
I mean, even as we're, for
those who are listening,
you know, talking on screen,
I'm thinking about the overlap between,
obviously we do work in different sectors,
but three black men on
this screen in academia,
talking about taking on
lots of different things,
trying to make impact.
So there's lots of different
directions that we could go.
But I definitely appreciate how you all
have been honest about that.
And, you know, tenure package coming up,
all these art exhibitions
coming up, playing in 2024.
I mean, there's so many
aspects that I can relate to
on that as well,
just in terms of things that
we've been doing and how far
in advance we have to plan,
things we have to say no to
in order to say yes elsewhere.
And so I think even that
sub-conversation is constructive
for listeners as we just
think about how we navigate
in these different spaces.
But even before we get to that,
'cause now you've both talked
about your work a little bit.
I was just gonna have you all
talk about your journey into
your academic professions
too, especially as black men.
And then as we also think
about this topic of black body.
So Imo, why don't we start with you.
How'd you actually get into
this work in the first place?
If there's a short version. (chuckles)
- I've always been an artist.
I was very fortunate.
I'm product of a divorced family.
My divorced home, that's
a part of my story.
My two Nigerian parents,
that's a part of my story too.
And, and so there's the...
When I came to New York
to live with my mom
and I began to really,
really jump into the art,
my art, the art scene,
I realized that I wanted
to go into this as an area.
And she encouraged me.
So I went to The High
School of Art and Design
and by the time I graduated,
I knew I wanted to go
into an academic space
where art wasn't what I was
focusing on necessarily.
So I went to Columbia and I
was an art historian there.
And the field of art history
allowed me the chance
to dive into research,
which is what I really,
really wanted to do on some level.
But I never stopped making
art. And so it was always very,
very confusing to the institutions
that I've been a part of,
included the one I'm at now
where I'm an art historian.
I don't teach studio art courses.
How I navigate between
the spaces of art making
and art interpretation.
And I think that there has
been this way that people
have wanted to place me into a box,
especially as a black man.
"You can't be a creator
and an interpreter.
You can't be both." And
I'm like, yes, I can.
White folks do this all the time.
They can be curators, they
curate their own spaces,
but there's something
about the way I present.
And I think it has a lot to
do with my big black maleness
that causes people to want to
put me in a particular box.
They didn't like it at Columbia.
They definitely didn't like it at Yale.
And at Westfield I think
they've embraced it
because they've seen what can
come from it in real time.
They've seen it.
And so this is a space that
I'm still trying to figure out
I'm being a very bad art historian.
I'm not doing a lot of writing right now,
but the work that I'm doing
is certainly contributing to the field.
And so this is where I am when
I speak to other students,
when I speak to students
and other people who
are thinking about diving
into art, they're like,
well, how did you do
this? And how is it like?
Well this is the pathway
that allowed me to,
this is the pathway I
chose to be a researcher
and to do art, not art on the side,
but art as really the center,
the creation process as
the center of my research.
And it's informed everything.
- Wow. Yeah.
I appreciate you sharing
that honestly too. I mean,
it's just from, you know,
kind of childhood on,
there's a lot we'll definitely
come back to and unpack there
that you've pulled out.
But just before we do that,
just wanna jump to Daniel
real quick and just hear
your story too about, you know,
how you've gotten into this,
this academic endeavor across
so many different aspects
of sociology.
- A lot of my own personal interests,
a lot of timing and a little bit of luck.
So I'll go back.
My parents had different religions.
Neither one of them was
particularly convicted.
Neither one of them ever took me to
either place of worship ever.
So I grew up without a conception of God.
Time when, that was, being an atheist,
let alone like, never
having believed in God,
was seen as very strange.
So that was always something that I liked
reading about and stuff like that.
So I had that one interest.
At the same time, my parents were also,
my mom's Jewish, my dad's black.
And so there was always really
interesting racial dynamics.
I grew up in an all black neighborhood.
My mom was the only white
person in the neighborhood.
So I always had lots of interesting
things happening about race.
And then my mom was born in the forties,
so she was raised at a time
when being Jewish wasn't all
the way encompassed into whiteness yet.
Later she accepted that she was white,
but up until like the seventies
she told me she fought it.
And, you know, so lots of
interesting things there.
And so I just always wanted to, you know,
explore the intersections
of a lot of those things.
And you know, I was one
of the kids that would
skip school sometimes to go to the library
'cause I was really focused on
learning about these things.
So I was reading philosophy
books and all that
at a really early age.
Had aspirations to be a philosopher,
actually got to Rutgers.
I went there 'cause at the
time it was the number one
philosophy program in the world.
Or maybe tied with Oxford and took
16 or 17 philosophy classes.
Loved my professors and
was the only black kid
in every single class except for-
And as I started reading this stuff,
I was like, man, this is
really stodgy. I don't...
There were a bunch of
issues I had with it.
So right at the end of
my undergrad career,
I had a bunch of professors
come to me and this, you know,
this was lucky for me, they said,
we think you have a lot of potential.
Have you ever considered these
other tangential sort of,
careers or where you want to go?
And they suggested public policy.
I actually had one put me
in touch with Cornell West
who talked to me and
we developed something
that I could have possibly done.
Personal circumstances
led me back to Maryland
and their sociology
program really embraced me.
And something like Imo
said, about 6'1", like 215,
and I literally had some of the
black professors at Maryland
and this was a really
important part of my life,
come to me, "You need to know
when you walk around here
the way you do and you
dress the way you do that
people are gonna see it a certain way.
It doesn't have to be good or bad,
but you need to be conscious
of it so you can operate
within these bounds and get
to where you need to go."
Dr. Patricia Hill Collins
was one of those people,
Dr. Kris Marsh, who just wrote a book
on the black middle class
called "Love Jones,"
was one of those people, Dr. Rashawn Ray.
So just having people fall into
my life at the right times.
And then as soon as I got in
the classroom, I loved it.
I could do and say so
many things that I thought
were valuable to me and the class.
And just since I TA'd my
first class, I was like,
I think this is such
a worthwhile existence
to be a professor, to engage in work
that'll eventually
trickle in the classrooms
and influence what people
read, what people think.
And so yeah, it was
sort of just a path that
just sort of happened before
me and I just took it.
- Yeah, I definitely appreciate
you sharing that story.
I mean, I think a lot of
people just, you know,
in hearing that will just
be able to gain insight
and maybe even understanding that
they didn't have before. Just, you know,
'cause sometimes I know for students,
when they walk into our classrooms
or see us in different settings,
they don't know the journey to get there.
It just helps.
- They're all so much
better high school students
than I was, or almost
all of them at least.
- Yeah. Which is scary for me sometimes.
So again, just appreciate
you both sharing that.
I mean, I know we're
gonna talk a little bit
about black biased representation
in art and society,
but just with what you both mentioned,
I just wanted to lean
in a little bit to like,
your own experience as black men.
Like what are some of the things,
'cause I know you both talked about
people kind of prepping you for that
in some ways or things that you saw.
What are things that surprised
you in your experience
and kind of how have you
navigated to thrive in a sense?
Dan, we'll reverse it and
start with you this time.
- So again, some of the things
that surprised me were just,
what was normal to me was
not, you know, acceptable,
was not within the bounds of
what people were looking for.
And definitely not what
people expected. Like I said,
I almost always went to
schools that were 75-80% black
even when I was in like
really advanced programs.
And so being smart, being articulate,
those things were not surprising.
And then all of a sudden I get to college
and people are offended
that I'm raising my hand
so much and that I have
opinions and that my God,
he actually knows the answer
before everybody else.
And I was not ready for that.
And so I definitely needed
people to help me out.
Again, understanding
that, navigating that,
not letting that bother me and, you know,
because those are really
good and important qualities
for the professor being in academia
and not to let those qualities, you know,
sort of be drained out or beaten outta me.
So again, now that I know
what I know as a sociologist,
I shouldn't have been
surprised by those things,
but I was, you know, 17, 18 years old.
And I had only had the
experiences that I had growing up
in Prince George's County.
Like I just showed my classes now,
we're talking about
contemporary segregation.
I live where my kids go
to school, PG County,
the school system has
120,000 kids, only 3% white.
Right? And so that is
the kind of experience
that I had basically.
And then again, going
to these PWI big states,
it was something that I needed help with.
And like I said, I've just been lucky
to have people there for me.
- Yeah. Just to follow
up a little bit on that,
and you talked about this a little bit,
but how are you helping
or informing or guiding
your students in that process too?
Even as you think about
your own experience,
the knowledge you have as a sociologist
and paying it forward, so to speak?
- Multiple things.
So one like, and sometimes they ask me,
but I generally dress like this every day.
Like in, not awful,
but like in a way where
I'm like, living my authentic black body.
To show them that, you know,
maybe some of these
stereotypes aren't right.
And, you know, I think sort
of just living that every day.
I know like Jody Armour and
Cornell West wear their afros
for the same sort of reason.
Like Jody Armour says
it's his hoodie. Right?
And so I try to live it
and I also, you know,
through my experiences,
try to, and I have,
I've been all over different demographics
because of my parents,
that I can sort of translate
a lot of what I have learned
across different spaces.
And so that's really what I
try to do in the classroom
is bridge any gaps, use myself as a foil
so we can just like, have a medium
to talk about these issues.
And yeah, so like I
said, I really try to use
that strength in terms of
across different groups.
- Yeah. That's really
good. Definitely powerful.
Imo anything you wanna add,
either to answer the question
about your own navigation
or even riff off of
anything that Danny said?
- Yeah, I was gonna mention
the notion of serendipity
or luck or like there's...
You know, for all of the
intelligence that people
have claimed I have or that
I have thought that I may have had.
I think so, so much of
my arrival, where I'm at,
has come from just the
kindness of just good people.
People who decided to
care at a particular time.
The idea that I've arrived
where I'm at by myself,
it's a false one.
And so I always find it really interesting
when I encounter, go to a conference,
or you speak to people
and it's almost like
they've prepared to be
Dr. So-and-so for so long
that you get a sense that-
The phone going off, for example,
in the middle of a conversation like this
would be catastrophic, right?
And I've just never been
able to arrive at this place
where I take myself so seriously
that I lose my sense
of humanity. You know?
And I think that's what my
students connect with the most.
I will sometimes dress like this in class
and sometimes I'm wearing a t-shirt
'cause I'm coming to class from the studio
and I'm going back to the studio to work
and I tell them what I'm working on.
I'm like, I'm working on this drawing
and it's kicking my butt right now.
You know, that's why there's
charcoal on my shirt.
But when I first came in
as a professor in 2009,
I thought I was supposed to be
wearing blazers or a suit or,
I just had this feeling that,
because I teach at a
predominantly white institution
and there was a sense that it was my,
part of my job or burden
was to make it clear
that I'm worthy of this.
That as a black person I can do this.
And to demonstrate to the
white kids in my class
that I really understand
my field and to demonstrate
to my department that I
was going to do this well.
Now...
Everybody could see
and continue to see now
that the level and the quality of work
I was bringing was way beyond
what they were even asking for.
But it was so hard for me to accept it
because there was this feeling
that I'm just above water.
I'm not actually there.
And at any given time,
a rouge wave could come
over and just drown me.
So when I first got
into Columbia University
from the High School of Art and Design,
it was a really, really big
deal for my high school.
I was wait-listed Harvard,
that was a huge deal, you know?
And I just knew that they
had made a mistake. In fact,
the first two to four,
I'll say two months of my
time at Columbia University
in my dorm room, I waited for notification
from the head of whoever
to say, we made a mistake.
You're not supposed to be here.
Because I was struggling
when I first got there.
I was stumbling through these classes.
I was trying to figure
out who I was and see
all this sea of white folks
and the few black people
that were at school were
trying to figure out
who they were too. And there's insecurity
and there are weird things
that are said because of that.
And it's like, I can look
back on it now and be like,
oh God, we were all so young and stupid
and just trying to figure things out.
But it still haunts me,
some of what I went through
that first semester until I
figured out how to do undergrad.
And then when I got to
Yale, it was even worse.
It was even worse because
this thing that we study
called art, art history,
this thing that we study,
which for me is not just a
thing to study. I live it.
I roll around in charcoal and paint.
This is what I do for fun, right?
It had become so dry and
philosophical. And here I am,
big black me in the class and
they're asking me a question
about the thing we just
read. And I'm like,
did we all read the same thing?
Because my take was so
violently different.
And the way I spoke was
so casual and I'm like,
this is art, I do this
every day. Like, no,
I don't care if you're using big words.
Like I do this every day, I know this.
And I just, it took me such
a long time to understand
that I was just coming from a
completely different worldview
from most of the people
at these institutions.
And that it wasn't my job
to change my worldview.
It was my job to just shine in the way
that I could in myself.
But it took a while.
It took a while. I wish I could say that
it was with great confidence
that I walked through
the halls of these institutions.
But even now, I shudder as I remember,
I shudder as I remember. Yeah.
- Wow. Well that's real.
And I know that people listening,
there's gonna be lots
of folks that are gonna
be able to relate to that
too. And then also in a sense,
even get encouragement from
you sharing the challenges
to know that okay, if they're
navigating through that,
it's not just them. Because like, I mean,
even as you described that
there's so much isolation in how
you just described that even
though you saw other people
navigating those same
pieces in isolated pods.
And I know my mental health
piece is coming out too.
But that's the first
thing that came to mind
as you were talking. Definitely.
- I don't think people talk
about the failures enough.
And I don't think people,
and when I say people,
I mean in general, academics.
But I think that black
academics in particular
should grow more comfortable
discussing the failures
because these spaces
haven't gotten any easier
for the next generation
of black and brown people.
They haven't become easier.
We're dealing with the same things, right?
And so the idea of not sharing, my gosh,
one of the things I share with
my students is I tell them,
if you, you know, if you
do well this semester,
remind me at close to end of the semester,
I will tell you my how I almost got kicked
out of Yale story.
You know, about how the paper that I,
the papers that I submitted
were so not up to par
because of all of my anxiety
that they almost threw me out.
I shared this conversation
openly with anyone
who will listen that I
graduated, got my PhD
and I'm doing very well.
But they almost threw me out.
They almost threw me out because
I was looking for myself.
And it took me so long to figure out
who I was at that school.
But I'm so comfortable sharing that.
I've seen other scholars
cringe when I talk about it.
I'm like, why are you cringing?
It's my story.
And somebody needs this.
- Exactly. Yeah.
Danny, anything you wanna comment on?
Either like from your own
experience or your lens?
'Cause you talked about that too, like,
now what you know, as a sociologist,
how that also impacted you looking back
and thinking about, okay,
that's why I was struggling
here or navigating this way.
Any thoughts in general?
- For sure.
And again, one, it was just,
my background was very different.
Like, both of my brothers
were street dudes,
had been in jail a lot.
And like, those are still
part of my influences.
And yeah, it just, I have
something specific actually.
So, and again, it has to do
with mannerisms and what's
normalized and what's taught.
So again, grew up talking,
conversing a certain way and
for whatever reason, again,
maybe it's because of
where I went to school,
never had grammar in any level of school.
Not in third grade, not in
fifth grade, not in ninth grade,
not in 12th grade. Never. Never. Right?
So I'm in all these AP
language classes in high school
and like, I write well, so I'm getting B's
but I'm always getting my papers
all marked up and whatnot.
And then I get to college
and the compository writing
or expository writing,
I forget what the name of the class was.
I'm getting really good grades in that.
And my teacher is really
impressed with the way
that I can interpret
passages and all of that.
And she even assigns me
to help a couple students
in the class that are struggling.
And then we take a final in that class,
which isn't graded by the
professor, but graded by
a random grad student in
the English department.
And it's graded very technically.
And I failed that final,
first semester freshman year.
And I had all A's in other classes.
So I was like, I can do this.
But it was this thing that I
was never taught and combined
with the fact that how I
normally talk and normally write
is culturally alien to
a lot of those people
that I ended up failing
that class and that,
you know, again, my mom was
really supportive of me in that,
my dad was really supportive of me.
My other professors were
really supportive of me
to not let that get me down.
But my second semester I had
to repeat a class. Right?
And I still ended up
graduating with honors
in philosophy and sociology.
But those trials are
real and a lot of times
just aren't prepared for them.
And you can't know, unless
you have somebody who has
the experience and knowledge,
you can't really know
that you're not prepared
for certain spaces.
And so.
- No, you can't know!
- I mean, I got an A in
the class the second time.
- Yeah. Wow. I mean that's
really, that's really poignant.
But I mean, I'm trying to
figure out how to say this,
but it just speaks to that
whole meritocracy commentary.
I know a lot of people have
been having that conversation.
Some might hear us and say,
oh, we're hearing this again.
But I still think sometimes
people just don't want to admit
that's 'cause you know,
you had another TA,
everything shifted at last minute
and someone from the
outside could be like, oh,
well he just didn't earn the same
X, Y, and Z as everybody else.
Ignoring the fact of what
you were exposed to early on,
how that impacts you in that situation
and how the other professor
was giving you feedback.
Like all of that.
And then how that's just
used to kind of, you know,
keep people in their place,
for lack of a better word.
- Still can barely use
a comma or semicolon.
Drop 'em in there haphazardly
and let editors fix it now.
- Yeah. Somebody needs to hear that.
Somebody's gonna need to hear
what you just said because...
Yeah.
It's such a-
I wish that I could look back
on all of these experiences
with fondness,
but there was so much of it
that was uphill fighting for me.
And so like, I-
But I do look at my
undergraduate experiences
with fondness because like I said,
there were people who
chose to just be kind.
They saw a diamond in the rough.
But I bring this up because
it was those decisions
that certain people made,
you know, Adam Rothman,
who was at that time, a PhD
student teaching a course,
and he's doing big things now,
but like, he pulled me aside.
He's like, Imo, when I see
an A I'll give you one.
Here's what you need to do.
And a lot of my issue was scaling back
how much I was saying,
because I was able to get
to the crux of my arguments
much faster with shorter papers.
There were two different
professors that pulled me aside
and said, oh God, you're
doing this all wrong.
You wrote seven pages here.
But the last four pages
were brilliant.
The first two made no sense.
Someone had to teach me how
to harness what they all said
was a gift for writing.
They all said, no, no, no,
you are one of the best
writer we've ever seen
at this stage. I'm like, I am? Like, yes.
Then why don't I have an A?
Because this is a terrible paper,
but we can see what you can do.
And so pulling me aside and
showing me line by line.
But it took time. It took time.
And so now as a professor,
I remember that, I remind
myself of that and my students,
I show them my old papers
and I sit with the ones
who really want to know.
And we go through it line
by line until we understand,
you know, how we can be better. You know?
But I can't, this-
For anybody who would say, you know, oh,
you know, well that has
nothing to do with race.
You're making everything about race. Like,
why are you talking about race?
Why would you bring up race
in this kind of instance,
because race was such a big part of it,
the fear of speaking in those
white spaces because you felt
like anything you said would
represent your entire race.
You know, having certain
professors pull me aside and say,
Imo you've been really
quiet in class lately. Why?
And not being able to admit that I heard
two white girls snickering in the corner
when I was speaking
and immediately thought
that I sounded stupid.
The professors had to find
ways to get me to speak.
And then once I was open,
it was like, it was over.
But, race is so much a part still
of this college experience.
Especially for black men in,
in schools such as these.
- Yeah. Yeah. Really well
said. And I appreciate, again,
just how open you are
with your students too,
and just kind of taking
them on that journey.
Danny, you look like you're
gonna reflect on something.
- Oh, no, I just really
agreed with what he said.
Try to employ a bunch of
the similar practices.
- Can I say one more thing?
- Yeah, yeah.
- There were these moments,
I know we're talking about black bodies,
or we will or we already are.
And there were these, there were-
I don't remember every moment of my time
at these institutions
but there are a couple
that stand out to me.
And there was one when I wanna say Yale,
in the music library is easily
one of the most extraordinary
beautiful things ever constructed.
It's just such a
beautiful space, you know?
So I would just go in there
sometimes and just sit there,
you know?
And I remember, and there
were these moments where
I would completely forget
who I was in this space.
And it was one particular time
I was walking by in there,
just, I greeted somebody really warmly
and they just looked me up
and down and I was like, okay.
And then I went to the bathroom
and I caught my reflection.
I'm seeing this big black, always sweaty.
There's a sweat on my book
bag. And I'm just like,
damn, I forgot.
I remember that moment.
When I saw myself in
the mirror and I'm like,
damn, I forgot. Like.
Why would anybody not greet
me or smile? You know?
And I was just reminded in that space.
It's like, negro, this ain't your space.
You know, this is how I felt there.
And I had a few moments like that.
But this is one that
just, I'm reminded of.
It's not that it was all gloom and doom.
I had some wonderful things
that happened at these
institutions to there in
undergrad studio Catesh.
I realized that my way into art history,
my way into art history as a study- Okay.
My way into research
of art history happened
through ethnography,
happened through sociology.
Opened up my whole
worldview. Like, I'm like,
wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
So I could study African
and African American artists
as a sociological project?
And he had me do an
independent study with him.
It's not easy, but he walked
me through that slowly,
methodically, carefully,
and brought me to this
place where I could begin
to understand how art
history and sociology
and archeology and all of
these things are very, very,
they're not as divided as you would think,
depending on what it is
you're trying to study.
As an Africanist in art history,
these things are all very, very connected.
And so I had good moments.
I just wanna make it
clear that the race part
is not something that's easily divorcable.
- It's part of it. Yeah.
- Well, I'll add one real
quick thing. And that is
both of us went to undergrad
at like the peak of like,
colorblindness in this system.
We weren't supposed to talk
about those things, right?
That's when they were like, oh,
get the chip off your
shoulder or whatever.
I think there's now a little
more space for talking about
those sorts of experiences.
But again, like 15, 20 years
ago there really wasn't.
So, yeah.
- Yeah, that's a really good point.
Just, I mean, just to pick
up on that a little bit too,
'cause the one thing we were
gonna talk about is just like
how you all think about these
topics in your current roles,
both what you do in
the classroom and like,
how it impacts society. So Daniel,
I was just gonna follow up with you.
Like, how does that,
'cause I know we've talked a lot about
the wealth gap pieces and
some of those other things
and how you introduce your
students to those concepts.
So how do you think about, I mean,
this isn't exactly what you do,
but how you think about the
concept of a black body,
even as you're teaching all
these different classes on all
these intersecting topics and
how you kind of pass that on
to your students to really make sure
they catch the realities.
- Right. Good.
One of the things I try
to drive home across
all of the different
subjects that we cover is
that there is so much
evidence that there is
a social and racial
hierarchy in this country.
Blacks. The most consistent thing
is that black people are
at the bottom. Right?
And so I try to,
depending on what we're covering that week
or whatever relates
something to that, right?
And so,
like today we were talking
about implicit bias, right?
And to literally show an
experiment done of, you know,
here's a white kid acting
this way in a park.
Here's a black kid acting
What are the reactions of
the society around gonna be?
The way that black bodies are treated
in each and every single,
you know, scenario,
for the most part is different and almost
always qualitatively worse, right?
There are some times where
I show them stuff and
they think it's white guilt
and that not necessarily worse or better,
but most of the time they think
that it's qualitatively worse.
And so that's what I try to
sort of get across, right?
And even in that one
specific video, right?
It just debunks so many
stereotypes that white people
are supposed to be scared of these like,
wildin thugs or whatever, right?
When in reality, it's
almost always the black body
that's put in jeopardy by acting any way
outside of the norm,
doing something deviant
that a white kid is allowed individuality
and not always confronted
about those things.
That black bodies are often
in really vulnerable positions
and often in really vulnerable positions
where authority figures have the ability
to do something to them, right?
Suspend them from school, arrest them,
put them in jail, right.
These sorts of things.
And that just, cumulatively,
it adds up to so much, right?
It adds up to stress, it adds
up to lower life expectancy.
It adds up to, you know,
building up all these stereotypes
about black deviance and criminality
when it's treated different
from the beginning.
And so, yeah, I just, I
insert body so they can
really understand and
empathize rather than
just see a bunch of numbers.
Like when I show the numbers
on the wealth disparity,
they don't wanna believe it.
The wealth disparity is 10x,
it's been 10x for 50, 60
years. I'll give 'em a quiz.
They don't want to, they
just don't want to know.
They'll still put two
times or four times, right.
But when I actually am able to get them
to visualize bodies or hypothetical
people it clicks better.
- [Imo] Wow.
Wow.
- Yeah. I'm still taking that in.
- Just get it wrong on the test
because I refuse to hear it.
- And it's been very
consistent. That one question,
especially across.
- It's very telling.
It's very, very telling.
It says it all, it says it all.
Okay. I, on my end, you know,
I mean they're the courses I teach,
but they're also the
special projects that I do.
And just by way of this
conversation we're having
about black bodies,
there was one that I did
at Westfield State University,
which is, like I said,
a predominantly white school.
And I should tell you,
here's how I arrived at this project.
It's a project titled "17 Years Boy."
And I still don't know
what that project was,
and I'm glad it's over
to be honest with you.
But before that project started,
here's what had happened.
Alright?
Donald Trump had recently
been inaugurated as president.
Determined at another time,
if any of the following
things were connected to him,
there was this huge
Charlottesville incident.
It was brought upon by riots,
by white nationalists
and white supremacists.
And there was a whole lot of wickedness
that looked white there, okay.
In Charlottesville. And people died.
One person died, two cops
died, three people died.
So that had happened.
Someone in my church, the
church I no longer attend,
predominantly white church,
white evangelical church,
had posted news to his
Facebook page, public,
he says, in response
to Black Lives Matters.
And all of a sudden, because
treason, they'll say,
you know, they're... you know!
No, no, not lynching,
traditional way of, you know,
treasonous would be,
so it's news, you know?
Well, yeah, we know the history
of black people with news,
but that's not what I meant.
So he posted that to his Facebook page.
I was...
I won't go into that story,
but a number of things happened
and didn't happen as a result of that.
And then school starts, and
two weeks into school starting,
black students are accosted
with racist language
written on their doors, "Nigger go home."
Or, "Niggers live here,"
or whatever it was.
Sounded very, very sixties.
It's really interesting how the language
hasn't changed much. So, you know, and so,
all of these things are happening
and there are people planning marches
because of the racist
incidents at Westfield State.
There were rape threats to
black girls that were there.
All kinds of things were happening.
That semester in particular was hot,
but it wasn't just at Westfield State.
It was happening around
the United States, okay.
At a number of different institutions.
And so I decided to have a
project that would look at
the life and death of Trayvon Martin,
because people were asking me,
are you gonna be at this protest?
Are you gonna be at this?
I'm like, everybody leave me alone.
You all go ahead and do your marching,
whatever's gonna make you feel better.
But I'm gonna do what
artists do. We make things.
And so I brought together,
it was a collaborative
project that involved
the 17 hour long, it took
four days to do painting
of a portrait of Trayvon Martin
that was destroyed at the 17th hour.
Nobody knew it was gonna be destroyed.
It was an extremely emotional work of art.
And many people are still
wondering what happened.
People were asking, well,
why is he doing this?
The people who were
criticizing it were like,
this doesn't make any sense.
That was, like six years ago.
But it was weird in the
room that I constructed,
you could hear the sounds
of the Zimmerman trial,
like that was playing.
So it was like you were
walking into a time warp
where we were six years prior.
We were all living in
that moment where this boy
who was brutalized,
was dragged through the Zimmerman trial,
it became the Trayvon Martin trial.
We all lived through that about how
he could be killed twice, you know?
And so there was this
conversation about black bodies
and the things that happened
to us and why, you know,
graffiti on doors such
as, "Nigger go home,"
or, "Niggers live here,"
in then, 2017, 2018.
Really, you can draw a line to it,
and it's a national one
and it's a local one.
And it confused a lot of people.
A lot of people felt good
that it was happening as well.
And I was completely
devastated when a very,
very high ranking person at the school,
when it was all done, came and said,
this has just been amazing.
When are you gonna do it again?
And I...
I looked at him.
Here we had put together art,
the music department had come together,
the English department, there were songs.
It was a very emotional thing
in commemoration of Trayvon Martin,
but also of 17 other boys
over the past century,
starting from 1915 who had
had things like this done.
So it was like, a shrine.
And this man came to me
and said, please, Imo,
we need to do more of this.
When are you gonna do this again?
And I was like, I don't know. Let's see.
The next boy's gonna be killed next week.
Let's put it together again.
It was very odd and
missing the mark, you know?
And so there is this way that
I can imagine that Danny
has poured himself out
into a lecture or into a
work of a piece of writing
or into a talk only to
have the point just.
- Oh yeah.
- Just gone.
And you wonder, are you
shouting into a void
that just consumes what
it is you're saying?
Is there any way that change happens?
Is what I'm doing, does
it actually move the...
Does it move anything?
You know? And that's
something that I wonder often.
I mean, I'm still, when I get off,
when I'm done with you guys, I'm going,
I'm working on the next thing
because the conversation has to continue.
But there is this fear
sometimes that people are seeing
the artistry and missing
the point. That worries me.
- Absolutely.
I've had a number of
instances like that, and yeah,
it is tough to deal with.
I would say that that's
where individual emails
or something like maybe
a text from a student,
even if it's a couple weeks
later be like, I get it now,
are really valuable resources
to, you know, keep you going.
- Yep.
- Yeah. That's, I mean, it's sobering,
but like those little
pieces, those little things,
like I said, make a huge difference.
Well, one thing just to, as
a last pivot, I'm curious,
and now I'm really curious,
just the way this conversation's
gone, I'm curious,
what keeps you all going?
Like, what gives you hope
in what you're doing?
Because I mean, we've
talked about, I mean,
there's obviously the passion
for the craft that you have,
but there's also the challenges
and you've done a nice job
of kind of laying out
that reality. But just,
I'm sure our listeners
are curious too, like,
why are you all still doing this work?
What keeps you moving?
Besides those texts and those messages?
Dan, do you wanna start?
- It's not the huge
academia checks either.
(everybody laughing)
- The collective laughter,
of course, oh gosh.
- We're relatively okay,
but we're not buying
any NFL franchise anytime.
So there are like real
world tangible things
that give me hope, right?
I've seen, since I've started
doing my work with atheists,
specifically black atheists,
there has been some
stigma lifted around that.
And that, especially
within the black community,
I've seen some of that stigma lifted.
And I think even, at least as importantly,
some of that more secular public figure,
black history reclaimed.
In terms of seeing more black faculty
in certain institutions really
trying to live up to ideals,
I do have hope from those things.
And so I try to lean into that,
that there is hope to fix the things
that have been really slow, right?
Like actual fixing or
narrowing of racial disparities
that has been slow going,
if no going at all, right?
The world disparity, home ownership gap,
those things are bigger than
when Dr. King spoke in 1963.
But the progress that I see
on the interpersonal side,
again, lends me to just
want to keep chopping
and hope that we can have
enough cultural understandings
and eventually some paradigm
shifts that lead to places
where we start to see
outcomes being more equal.
We start to see the qualitative treatment
of different groups being much more equal,
much less disparate.
And so that's really the
world that I'm hoping for.
I think that it's achievable.
I've seen individuals make the change.
So that's what gives me
hope. The thing that,
you know, scares me is just
how incentivized racism has become,
on the right wing especially.
And that is a very strong competing force
to what I want to see.
And it has a lot of money
and it has a lot of power
and it has a lot of
structural things going for it
in terms of minoritarian
government prevailing
quite a bit in this country.
And so, yeah.
I hope that makes sense. Right?
I've got to overcome that
obstacle because of the
things that I've seen
within people, especially.
Again, some institutions,
because the institutions
have been very slow to
change in this society.
- Yeah. And I definitely
appreciate that perspective.
I mean, as I'm reflecting
on what you're saying,
it actually reminds me of the
story you were talking about
with the wealth gap and
how you just, you know,
you're continuing, 'cause
that's in a microcosm.
The students might not
be seeing it at first.
You package it in a different
way. Eventually they catch it.
And just hearing you talk about
that on the societal level
in terms of stigma for black
atheists or other types of
things that are moving
at the individual level
institutionally, that gives
me hope hearing you say that.
'Cause I know that's a
tension that I feel often,
especially I know even in
this podcast, like, okay,
well what am I doing in the lab?
What am I doing with students?
Is it making a little difference here?
Is it making a difference society wide?
And it almost sounds
too selfish in a sense.
'Cause it's almost as if I'm saying,
where am I feeling like I'm
actually making an impact
in someone's life or in
someone's lives or in society?
So to kind of hear you package that for me
is also just really helpful.
- That reminds me of something
I said to my wife when,
about two or three weeks ago,
there was the fallout of
Beyonce not winning the Grammy.
I don't keep up with the award shows,
I think it was a Grammy.
And I said to her, well, I don't,
I didn't listen to that
album, but she did.
I heard it in the back. It was okay.
But I said to her 30 years ago,
we wouldn't have even had
a public discussion about
should a black woman have won a Grammy.
So we need to acknowledge what's racist,
what kind of bias they're
going on over there.
But also that there's
hope because we are in
a different space than we we used to be.
- Yeah, that's true.
That's good perspective.
Imo, I'm gonna give you the last word.
- My hope is in the relationships
that I'm forming with,
I think some of the most
extraordinary people
as I create and as I deal with
the various themes, you know,
in my work as an artist, as a professor,
and just as a human being.
So the relationships bring hope for me.
I'm not working in a vacuum.
Things are happening.
The world is moving.
And what I do as an artist
is just another offering.
It's another offering and an
opening for a conversation.
I sometimes find it easier to
deal with my emotions around
a series of things, you know,
through the avenue of art.
And what I like about it is that,
I don't always know what I'm doing.
In fact, most of the time I don't.
I don't do sketches before
I do the final work.
I just, it comes out as a
unit, that's how I work.
And it's pretty honest when it does,
it's perhaps more honest.
I'm more honest in line
than I am when I'm speaking.
And there's something
childlike about making things,
starting at nothing and then making it.
There's something a little
narcissistic about it.
I'm deciding that that
is going to be something
when anybody looking at it
can say there's nothing there.
And so somewhere in that tension between
a God complex and a
child is the opportunity
for a new kind of conversation to start.
And because God is
always making new things,
I just don't know what
it's gonna look like.
I don't know what it's gonna do.
And there's hope in not knowing
if that makes any sense.
Like, we think that, you know,
we think we know what the
next five minutes will bring.
And the fact is we don't.
There's somewhere in
there that gives me hope,
that something really
extraordinary could take place.
I think it's child-like,
but I'm okay with that.
In terms of being a
teacher or a professor,
it's still in the relationships.
When I teach my art survey courses,
it's a general course in art history.
I always start with
Africa. I have my reasons.
I've never been a part
of an art survey course
in my training that has
started with Africa.
I start with Africa and we
go through it and I have,
in one of my classes,
I have one black kid,
two black students.
And this one guy, he's just sharp.
He's a brilliant young
man. He's a first year.
And I was talking about
something I forgot.
It was a video showing of
some ritual or a ceremony and
there were women dancing
and I was talking,
I was trying to stay focused,
but I panned the room as I
was giving this impassioned
end of the lecture and
the smile on his face.
He was just looking at the
screen. It looked cartoonish.
He was beaming ear to ear,
and he waited till after
class to meet with me,
and he's like, I don't know how to.
Look. I'm African-American.
You know, that's Africa.
There's gotta be some
kind of genetic memory.
I know those women, I
know how they're moving.
I get that. Like I feel
like I'm related to them.
So he was explaining,
he didn't know that I saw
this big grin on his face.
But he was explaining how he
was feeling in that moment.
And I'm like, I'm supposed to
be at this school right now.
He needs this.
And there's students like
him that need this right now.
And so there's hope in that for me.
There's hope that I'm
in the right position
at the right place and time.
That my being in this particular
moment means something
to the people who are gathered around me.
And I'm okay with just that.
- It's a great juxtaposition
from the undergrad,
not feeling like you sould
be here to that moment.
Giving you the exact opposite feeling
of I should be here.
And this is exactly why.
- Yeah.
- It's awesome.
- Great illustration. Wow.
Well, I'm grateful of both of you, one,
for just the work that you
all do on a daily basis.
I mean, even, not despite,
but amidst everything that
you all navigate just to
even to get to where you
are as you all shared so,
so powerfully and eloquently.
And then just the impact it's
having on that generation.
Definitely full circle as Danny mentioned.
So thank you to both of you for the work.
Thank you for taking time outta
your schedules to actually
be here to share this.
I know listeners are gonna
get a lot out of this.
I'm just anticipating there's
so many things that people are
gonna be able to relate to
or have their eyes open to
at the same time, or a little bit of both.
So definitely appreciate
what you're all doing.
Hopefully this will give
other people hope as well
as we all try and move
forward as a society.
So Danny, Imo, thanks
so much for being here.
Definitely appreciate both of you.
- Awesome. Thank you.
I had a blast. This was...
- I had a blast too.